the single greatest pursuit of every
young person today is the pursuit of
meaning I'm Dave Rubin and before we get
to it today here's my weekly reminder to
subscribe to our channel and click the
bell so that you actually see our videos
a crazy concept indeed all right joining
me today is the founder and president of
the Ravi Zacharias International
Ministries and the author of several
best-selling books on Christianity Ravi
Zacharias welcome to the Rubin report
David thanks so much for having me I've
looked forward to this for a while and
honored to be with you it's an honor to
have you here I'm looking forward to it
as well this is one of those that the
internet sort of forced to happen over
the last century over the last two years
you you've been on the list of when
people just start assaulting me on
Twitter and I mean it assaulted the best
sense sit down with Ravi sit down with
Ravi so we finally were able to work it
out okay so you know that's so both of
my friends went to work I guess yeah
there you go all right so first when I
google your name it says that you're a
Christian apologist now we all hear this
phrase and it sounds a little strange to
me Christian apologists as if to do what
you do you have to either apologize for
something or feel guilty about it or
something like that can you tell me
about the phrase Christian yeah it's one
of those words that have evolved over
the last few years and contoured with
different meanings now David but it has
a rich history when it goes back to the
likes of Justin Martyr and Augustine and
so on apologetics was part of the
curriculum and the discipline of
theological philosophical training it
comes from the Greek word actually to
give an answer the Apostle Peter says
for example set apart Christ in your
hearts as Lord and always be prepared to
give a reason for the hope that is
within you and to do it with gentleness
and respect so there's an ordinary
fisherman talking about how to answer
people with gentleness and respect so
the word really means to give an answer
I think it has to set two senses making
your truth claims clear and giving the
answer to the legitimate questioner but
you know it sounds like apologizing and
then it has taken on negative
connotation yeah I hear you're an
apologist for something it's immediately
oh wow I'm gonna really be dumped on
right here
so we ourselves are thinking whether
that dome is a good description of what
we do historically it was accurate but
in current usage I'm not quite sure it's
the best word do you have a better
phrase then so the next time I bring you
on I don't have to say it because I do
think that that connotation there's
something that in a modern sense it's
like oh he's going to come here and
explain his view on Christianity yeah
but it will have a but that will lead to
something else well I have we pondered
it there's not a catchphrase that has
come into our mind but we as a team have
now I've got 93 speakers who work with
me in 15 countries and so we're thinking
of you know many of them are legitimate
philosophers I find that a bit of a
glorifying term for myself I'm not a
philosopher in an academic sense but I
do some very serious thinking on matters
that deal with culture values ethics and
so on it's probably the best description
is that of a Christian thinker and and
the contextual representative of values
and the substrata of culture all right
we'll find a term thinker I mean that
works christian figure that works for me
okay so before we get into to the meat
of what your ideas are in things like
that I thought that because so many
people on Twitter were asking me to have
this conversation are you amazed at the
way information and ideas both good and
bad can travel so fast now that you can
get your ideas out across the world you
know with the click of a button we're
years ago and you know 30 some odd years
ago and you started doing this and
before that even that it could take a
lifetime to get those ideas across well
I really am in fact when I was with our
mutual friend Ben Shapiro he surprised
me by saying you were the most requested
guest to be brought on this program that
also quite shocked me flattering and
encouraging but yes I think you don't do
a Ben Shapiro impression my brain
doesn't work as processes I don't know
that that guy's sort of a rap artist and
prose no he just moves I've watched your
dialogue with him that was brilliant
by the way yeah and you know David I'll
be honest with you I'm wondering if time
will tell whether this was a good thing
or a bad thing
hmm and the reason is good is naturally
attractive but evil is naturally
seducing seductive and whether the wrong
side of this will triumph someday
because all you've got to do is get one
idea out there and you get a following
for it and destruction comes easier than
construction so I I sort of holding out
on whether this is good or bad I love
the fact that if I'm sitting in my hotel
room in Delhi away from my home in
Atlanta I can google and find out
information almost anything that's going
on out here I love the fact that I can
call my children instantly like that but
at the same time all the farcical stuff
all the hollow stuff all the negative
stuff all the destructive stuff that
goes on we're building a culture of hate
and that troubles me do you think that
that concept right there is sort of
everything that a religious thinker
regardless of what religion is really
dealing with the the sort of battle
between you know a certain set of ideas
versus modernity and you don't know like
we're in the internet right now we don't
know which way this is going to go
because you can spread the bad it just
as I would say more easily you can
spread the bad than to spread the game
so to speak I think sort of some
rebellion finds it easier to find souls
that have got nothing else to do you
know they're sort of Shakespeare would
talk of them of the rattle of a half of
vacant soul or someone who's just not
got enough to keep them busy the Tower
of Babel is a good example you know why
did God step down to confuse the
languages because unanimity in
destruction can go and wreak havoc
however it's here to stay
and this is only the beginning yeah I
you are an author I'm an author the
value of having access to information is
a good thing that's why it is important
what we do in training the souls and the
thinking of people that's what I'm
committed to okay so now let's talk
about your journey
here because it's been an interesting
one you you were born in India and you
were you were an atheist until you were
17 is that right
again sometimes these thumbs became
floated around in stronger ways than I
would like to have I was indifferent to
religious claims India's probably the
most religion manufacturing culture on
the face of the earth but most of the
major isms Hinduism Buddhism Sikhism
Jainism all of these isms were spawned
and raised in India and in India and
Pakistan have not separated there have
been the biggest Islamic nation - so
actually religion had no attraction for
me that's the best way to put it I felt
it was believing the incredible and it
was creating more havoc what was that a
strange position to hold as a young
person in a place that all those isms
came from I think so
but you know we never ever discussed it
I don't drive played cricket and I
played tennis so I was a sportsman in
school that's where you really talk
after a game or whatever I don't ever
remember getting into these discussions
it flows with the culture but the notion
of God as a real entity never entered my
mind yeah maybe during examinations
you know God if you're up there could
you help me and so on I never took
interest suddenly not in the Christian
faith even though my ancestors came from
the highest caste of the Hindu
priesthood in the deep south they were
called in abou threes then somewhere
along the way there was a conversion
that took place into the Christian faith
and then that was lost it became very
nominal so I was really raised I didn't
have a single Christian friend they were
all either Hindu Muslims about this so
we never talked about these things and
then having had a crisis experience in
my life that changed everything so let's
talk about that
yes India is a culture of academic
excellence if you're not doing well
there you're in trouble and it's also a
culture of shame when you're not
succeeding academically so I did the
horrific thing I'm till this day
embarrasses me because I don't like
talking about it took me a long while to
talk about it I attempted suicide when I
was 17 and it was not out of any
neurological disorder it was not any
biochemical thing it is a fact that I
just didn't have meaning there was no
purpose in life for me David I was
moving towards failure after failure
after failure in contrast to my brothers
and sisters and my father and so tried
to poison my system I thought it was
going to be successful I just didn't
like the way life felt and I wanted to
kill that feeling and to me the only way
to do that was you know what they say in
Belgium now there's such a high rate of
suicides they don't call it suicide
anyway they call it opting out of life
that were a bit a good description for
me but it is on that hospital bed a
Bible was brought to me my body was
dehydrated I couldn't hold it but the
man who brought it to me and gave it to
my mother and scripture passages were
read to me and you know when you're
desperate when you're lying like that
words become very important to you and
when the words of Jesus were read to me
because I live you also shall live that
lit up within my heart well what passage
is that again John chapter 14 and verse
19 jesus starting to Thomas of all
things because Thomas was the Apostle
who went to India and the irony of it
isn't that same passage Jesus says I'm
the way the truth and the life no one
comes to the Father except through me
it's pretty exclusive claim dramatic
claim and he went to a land of 330
million deities and he paid with his
life to present the Gospel message of
Jesus so that would like that verse
jesus said because I live you also shall
live I latched on to the word live I
said I don't know what this really means
but if God has a different definition of
this than I have I want to know what
that is and in a simple prayer I began
my pilgrimage to faith in Christ
what was that shift like I mean if we if
we were writing a movie right now so
there's the the young man who you know
attempt suicide the Bible comes to him
at in in the hospital bed he has the
wake up I mean it sounds like a movie
sort of what was the next
than that because it doesn't all just
happen immediately like well I
appreciate you asking these questions
because you know a they are pretty
pointed and pretty real to me the
problem we often think Jesus Christ came
into this world to make bad people good
that's wrong it's not got anything to do
making bad people good it's coming to
the world to make dead people live I was
dead to the claims of God upon my life I
had no purpose how do you find purpose
without a transcendent moral first cause
you can only lift yourself up by your
own existence your bootstraps and assign
your own meaning the fact that I was
created for a purpose that I had an
individual distinctiveness that nobody
else had that God had a purpose for me
in life these were strange concept now
of course I'm looking in retrospect a
when you go back at that point my
biggest hope was like looking for a life
a life guard or a life jacket but over
the process I found out and I say this
David I travel I've got about 70
countries
I speak hundreds of times a year the
single greatest pursuit of every young
person today is the pursuit of meaning
what does my life really mean even as
I'm talking to you I was talking to a
young man yesterday 18 years old who got
hooked onto pornography when he was 8
and he says and I've hated everything
that I have become and now all I want to
do is make an exit you see you take
something and warp it into something
else you empty it see you empty the
reality with something that's hollow so
that's what I done with life so to me
the biggest change and my father said
this on his deathbed actually before he
went into the hospital for bypass and
when he lost his life he said to me what
happened in your life is the most
incredible thing
I have watched happening from being a
failure to the different hungers and
desires you have so what Jesus I believe
did for me was changed not only what I
did but change what I wanted to do that
I never left the top three in the class
after that I always used to be in the
bottom three
so my hungers changed my desire has
changed and I think that is the big
transformation I noticed that's an
incredible statement for your father to
make right before passing did he have a
similar awakening or once you had an
awakening did it go across the family
yeah actually my brother and my sister
was amongst the first to latch onto this
and then me you know when Jesus talked
to Nicodemus he made a fascinating
statement he said you can't change on
your own you have to experience the new
birth now I know that takes on a
pejorative term in our ways but the fact
of the matter is new desires new hungers
our new breathing a new air and when he
watched my life change and what happened
yes he followed him which is very
unusual in the Indian culture there you
all follow your parents very rare for a
parent to follow the children but he
asked me to take him to the hospital he
was gonna have bypass I'm talking about
1979 so you know you're talking about 40
years ago it was relatively new my dad
was overweight he was asthmatic and
things had gone wrong physically but he
elected to have surgery but he had this
premonition said I don't think I'm gonna
make it he was closer to my older
brother hmm I was number two more like
my older brother and temperament but he
phoned me I lived in Niagara Falls
Ontario at that time 90 miles away sorry
five miles away he asked me to come and
take him to the hospital and on our
drive to the hospital that was a
conversation and he said what God has
done in your life and he also had had
that transformation through the work of
God in his heart you said the phrase
existential bootstraps which I like that
that that's kind of interesting do you
think some people can do it by
themselves do you think some people can
grab the existential bootstraps and not
have a religious belief or something
beyond themselves and still live a good
and moral life and a meaningful life
let's say I think so I think they can
but it does not have ultimate grounding
in a rationally compelling way it has
only that an existence or transformation
so yes of course they can and I have
many of my friends who are like that
they are good people they are decent
people
and I enjoy those friendships because we
have great conversations but the
question has to be David is what you
believe ultimately true or only
individualistically true for you and for
me and if that is the case then you
cannot absolute eyes it you can only
recommend it as pragmatically
workable for the now and then how do you
dissuade somebody who by their own
existence or bootstraps have come to the
opposite conclusions
there's no antic referent there's no
point of reference to find a solution to
what is true and good and beautiful so
this has come up with many of the people
that I've had on the show from a
religious perspective from a theists
perspective sort of this micro verse
macro argument wherever you all of the
religious people that I've had on here
have said what you said there which is
that yes of course at the micro
individual level you can have atheists
I've got plenty of their books right
here who are friends who are good moral
decent people but almost that you can't
organize a society around that which is
sort of loosely that's the jordan
Peterson perspective on this which I
think you you probably prescribe to yes
I think Jordan Peterson's conclusions
are terrific his foundation is weak I
think that the edifice he has built on
his presuppositions I would love to get
together with him one day because I love
eyes I will see if I can make it could
you do that it would be an honor because
I I mean the way he was treated at
Cambridge you know this plan to go there
is totally unlikable what exactly I mean
an educational institution to do that to
a man of his repute and his capability
you know just briefly the the saddest
part about that is you probably know I
was on tour with him for the year so I
was with him when he found out he was
getting the fellowship at Cambridge it
was the happiest I've ever seen him and
the idea that putting aside why they did
it
he has spread the ideas that you're
talking about here even if you don't
agree with his his methods completely he
has done more to spread these ideas
across the world in the last two years
than anyone on earth I
argue and then they decided no no you
can't you can't and I think he is
outstanding you know I couldn't stand up
to his intellectual prowess he's a man
of incredible ability and courage and I
am and he's from Toronto you know and my
I'm from Toronto actually a from Delhi I
moved to Toronto my family's all in
Toronto my wife's from Toronto I have a
very great respect for Jordan Peterson
but let me give you an illustration no
in Ohio Columbus Ohio there's a building
called the Wexner Center for the Arts
supposedly the first postmodern building
and I asked the person what is a
postmodern building I know what
postmodern philosophy is what's the
post-war but he said well the architect
said if life itself has no purpose why
should our buildings have any purpose
and so he built it with no particular
purpose in mind you know as stairways
that God knows I say he said what do you
think of it I said I have one question
did you do the same with the foundation
you cannot fool with the foundation you
can fool with the infrastructure and so
to me when Peterson talks of absolutes
when Peterson talks of right and wrong
not so much right and left but right and
wrong his his conclusions are very good
but the only reason I think those
conclusions stand if there is an
ultimate eternal purpose for life itself
otherwise it's just one ideology against
other especially dare I suggest because
of a pluralistic society in which we
live
people start from different points in
the beginning of the argument and that
to me is where I think there is the
weakness but its conclusions and his
arguments I find very persuasive and
very likable if ultimately the
conclusions are right let's say and you
know you can argue about the the little
methods to get there do you think that
can be enough yeah I had you not use the
word enough outer said yes do you think
that's valuable do you think that's a
good way to at least have a culture I
can see why you're not gonna go with
enough okay I got a foundation part of
it is to me indispensable because that's
what you have built
your theory on however for a coexistence
for a respectability for civility I
think it's good and I think that's why I
enjoy talking with somebody like you
even disagreement can be allowed
provided provided you don't get
disagreeable in the process and I think
Peterson is very impressive that way I'd
love to talk to him on why he has not
moved in that one step see dennis prager
for example dennis prager and I have had
several dialogue going through my
greatest hits over here Greg hi funny
articulate intellectual but we do agree
on one thing as a starting point that
the ultimate pursuit of life had Praeger
and for me was communing with God and
the starting point is that God has a
moral law at work in this universe when
you start from that even if you come up
with some divergent discussions on who
this God is you can have intelligent
debate but if you start purely from an
autocracy of good and bad then you run
into a problem in a pluralistic culture
so you basically you can't start from
the position that we we all can have our
thoughts and that they're all sort of
equal because the conversation can sort
of never get anywhere versus that there
is some moral authority beyond us and
then what you may believe related to
Jesus is obviously different than say
what dennis prager believes but but you
relish in that conversation basically
yeah and you know this is really what
I'd said and that wonderful conversation
with ben shapiro whom i admire so much a
great great thinker and you know I said
to Ben there's a there's a struggle
going on right now it's between the two
words egalitarianism and elitism and I
said to him we are meant to be equal as
people but not all ideas are equal we
have reversed it we have made an elitism
of people and an egalitarian ism of
ideas and that is flawed as a starting
point so if I respect all of my fellow
human beings regardless of what their
view is and see them of intrinsic worth
not worth given by the government or
state but an intrinsic valuable entity
we can converse and dialogue and
ultimately truth will triumph in the end
and so I think it is important to have
civility which is lost in America what
is what America is witnessing right now
is the destruction of sensible dialogue
do you think that's happening across the
West it seems to me the amount of emails
I get and what I'm reading and from the
countries I visited in the last year
it's not just the US but it's starting
to happen everywhere in different
degrees at the West is grappling with
something I think so but you know it's
also happening in the East the only
differences in the East it is squelched
right from the beginning there's no free
expression in China I mean China China
is making huge strides in this world I
think in a demagogic way
globally while we're trying to worry
about each other's tax returns out here
they are building a global Empire and
we're not taking note of what it is
they're doing it's happening even in my
homeland in India there's a lot of
trouble beneath the surface in the
invasion of the private probe belief and
so on the thing is in America America is
a commercial culture everything spreads
faster so we notice it more here and
I've now lived here for many years and
I'm saddened to see what we are doing to
ourselves because this is a great nation
this is a great foundation so I came in
here as a stranger and God gave me the
blessing of coming here and my raising
my family and enjoying success I don't
think I'd have enjoyed this back where I
from whence I came but now what we are
doing is the vitriol the invective the
poisonous Barb's and statements we can't
seem to disagree without bringing the
person down stay with the year you know
as a debater you know we don't go with
ad hominem arguments that's a sign of
weakness anybody who attacks you
personally David is telling me they
can't deal with your argument so they're
dealing with you so I actually wasn't
planning on going here but I think this
is pretty rich place to move so what
then do the people that are trying to do
what you're trying to do trying to do
what I'm trying to do
that are trying to have conversations
what do you do in the midst of a world
that is about ad hominem attacks
personal attacks you know what people
are now are calling canceled culture and
mob outrage to silence everyone what do
you do because cuz I sense that it may
not just be enough to talk about the
right ideas now that at some point you
hit the end of the road with that you're
doing it well David you're doing it well
you know I commend you for it you're not
a provocateur you are not stirring up
people do it be angry I'm a little worse
on Twitter and then remember but you are
intelligently engaging and that's what
we are doing you know I'm 73 now I've
been in this work since I was 26 some
done it for nearly half a century as
long as I've been married I've been on
numerous campus or globally Islamic
campuses Hindu campuses Buddhist
campuses atheistic campuses and I was
given an honorary Doctorate from a
Marxist University in Peru you know how
and their San Marcos an honorary
Doctorate was a guy was shocked and
there but the first time one of my
colleagues went there they blocked them
they didn't want to hear them and I said
what happened how come and they said you
know you're getting us thinking noble
thoughts good thoughts you're getting us
thinking in the ways that we ought to be
thinking we've not reached there yet so
I believe ultimately God give us a book
which means the word is very important
and just speaking nearby the night
before I'm speaking to you the number of
young kids young kids who say what's
your new tube listen to this I've
listened to that I think our only hope
without coercion is to put the ideas out
there and hope that hearts will change
and that truth and beauty will win out
in the end rather than that which is
hideous and that which is false do you
think part of this is that the secular
world has sort of handed us so much
meaningless crap I mean you know that
that now there's a there's a sort of
renaissance in television but that so
many the movies it's - everything seems
to be in fact
with some sort of postmodern view of the
world and that then causes a young
person that maybe wouldn't have listened
to a 73 year old a couple years ago now
go oh wait a minute I saw this on
YouTube and that actually doesn't sound
nearly as crazy as the stuff that
Hollywood's handed me you know one of
the nicest things I don't like to talk
about what people say in their
compliments one of the nicest things a
young man said to me he walked over to
my colleague and he said Tim when I'm 73
I hope I can be like that you know that
tells me that when they look at what is
an ideal to them they want to emulate
and they want to be in that way but
you're right secularism led us to a
bankruptcy of values it led us not only
to a bankruptcy of values it led us to a
an impoverished way of conversing with
each other what do we see on the news
people fighting people arguing that's
not what the news is all about give me
the news I have the intelligence to
figure out what is true and what is
right and what is wrong here so is is
that though purely the result of
secularism or is that the result of just
a little bit of human nature also that
isn't just a secular thing but just that
people click things that are you see
something bad you click it you see
something good and it just sort of let
you let it go like that that's the
battle between religion and secularism
constantly oh yeah you're right and to
point that out but I think if we take
the term secularism or secularization
okay it's a process by which religious
ideas institutions and interpretations
have lost their social significance
that's the classic definition of
secularization the very word circular
means this worldly and so if I don't
respect you as a fellow human being I'm
going to fight you to the bone but if I
say this man has every right to his
belief and the integrity of his belief
and to defend it then I'm not fighting
you I'm discussing ideas but what
happens I think David is we put faces to
beliefs and if we don't like that face
we attack the person yeah let me give
you an illustration I'm a great lover of
hockey follow the NHL like Robin in
Canada you have no choice you know and
so that's your other religion yeah yeah
except I don't give any offerings the
thing is what is a what is a sports
writer do he doesn't just say in the
days that I was watching it you know
that Boston Bruins are coming into town
it's Bobby Orr and Johnny McKenzie and
Phyllis pizzette oh they make it a
personal thing because we follow persons
as soon as you watch a sport they like
to identify an individual who be the
face of that particular team because
then you get the adrenaline going if
you're just talking about two great
hockey teams playing each other the way
I think it used to be even the Montreal
Canadiens came to play the Toronto Maple
Leafs it was hockey at its best so I
think the personification of an idea and
the embodiment of an idea has created
this spirit of negativism and so even in
politics yes I was just gonna say I mean
you're talking about cult of personality
which is exactly what politics is but
they don't tell you what so and so far
what what law has been passed who
bastard
who did this who said that and the
moment you show the picture of the
person the anguish gets into you so
you're gonna fight it whether you like
the idea or not so I think this personal
attack in our culture the day of
personal assassination that is what has
happened in the way we discuss ideas and
I'm not given into that but I'm invited
to places where they really want to get
into a fight or something I said no
thank you I'm the wrong person I want to
have an intelligent conversation and
trust the audience to make up their
minds so as someone that lives in the
United States now that originally from
India went to Canada a couple of things
that you've referenced here have sound
very in line with the Constitution of
the United States and the Declaration of
the United States that we have god-given
rights and yet at the same time these
were the men who were guaranteeing your
freedom from religion
that that's very much in line with what
you're talking about actually well the
freedom off religion yeah and yeah and
when you take that very statement that
we hold these truths to be self-evident
what do we mean by that now no
self-evident truths anymore in our
postmodern my mindset was modernity
ultimately does away with truth meaning
and certainty so what do we talk about
as self-evident and then what are the
self-evident truths that we are endowed
by our creator with these unalienable
rights of life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness here's what I want to say
David no other worldview would have
generated a stay a statement like that
kicks of the judeo-christian worldview
because you break it down phrase by
phrase and so many worldviews would say
no I don't agree with that I think the
framers of the Constitution and the
writers of the Declaration of
Independence and said you know we put
our names with our sacred honor the the
sacredness of life and the sacredness of
your word this had the potential to be a
great nation but in the last 50 years we
are seeing this dismantled and falling
apart just by the volume of words that
oftentimes are incoherent so how do we
reverse some of that because it's very
obvious that that people are waking up
to this people don't want the chaos
that's why people are paying attention
to all of these things on you I think so
much has changed globally David you know
it's noise you said earlier not just the
United States I could name four or five
countries to you where there is more a
radical type of politicization of ideas
that have made the people shocked and
surprised with how the particular
elections went we don't like what we
have so we like to try something new
it's not so much that the politician
produces the culture as much as the
culture produces the politician so where
do we change my own honest opinion on
this I think it's going to get a lot
more worse before it gets better
but if there is a change it is gonna
have to change in the academic world mhm
what we are teaching our students is
bringing itself out into the open our
faculty members
to learn to have intelligent
disagreement and dialogue not so
programmed the students into thinking in
one particular way and I think the
Academy has failed in America do you
think it can come back because this is
this is being debated constantly now
that that academia now is so rotten that
the systems and the gatekeeping is so
infected there's a lot of people that I
think are making a sound argument that
it basically just all has to collapse of
course what can come on the other side
of a collapse could be a lot worse and
that's what we have to I don't know why
Paul Johnson's book on intellectuals
it's very powerful book the closing
paragraph itself is pre here as a
historian and he talks about how
intellectuals have so shaped and
programmed culture and very often their
own private lives are in complete
disarray and fall apart and imploding I
think the answer to your question is is
there hope is there gonna be change I
think so let me give you an illustration
of this I'm pretty sure this is correct
but I'm not verified it but a
congressman wrote to me and he said when
Ronald Reagan was shot Tip O'Neill went
to the hospital and sat by his bedside
and prayed for him for Ronald Reagan
they were opponents on a platform of
political debate but when one of them
was wounded with a bullet the other man
came and sat by his bedside and prayed
for him that would never happen today
what has changed
so my way of thinking what did it take
to change the scourge of slavery what
did it take to move the scourge of
racism in a different direction
oftentimes it took a handful of people
it didn't take mighty armies you can
just about name the individuals you know
whether it was Wilberforce um there are
people like dr. Martin Luther King out
here and so on
they changed history I look at my
grandkids and I hear statements coming
out as some of them which are amazing to
me at ages 7 & 8 they'll say things and
I say wow where did that come from I'll
give you an example
my grandson on Good Friday had his
teacher wash the feet of the children
first graders she wash their feet
so this little guy Jude who is now eight
was seven then pastor can we wash your
feet today so they brought a basin of
water these little kids put her feet in
the basin of water and washed her feet
and then he says the teacher wrote this
to my daughter say you'll now believe
what your son Jude did today they washed
my feet and then he looked at her and
said your feet are now clean but your
heart is even purer and our hearts are
pure because we have met you when a
little one seven years old yeah can make
a comment like that the right time the
right person will arise and change the
course of history is there a way to make
that happen sort of on a global scale
like is there or do you think at all so
that's just basically your view is that
it's a bottom-up thing ironically right
yeah I think so
is that an odd place for a religious
perspective I was gonna qualify that I
said it's a bottom up in that it has to
start from the foundation but it's a top
down it has to have begin with a
transcendent worldview of who we are in
our essence so and that's why I think
it's consistent God doesn't just change
what we do it changes what do we want to
do and so the transformation will have
to come from a transcendent eternal
purpose but the transcendent purpose
changes us foundationally so it's a
top-down bottom-up and neither is
excluded so if there was a say a healthy
society that was incorporating all of
the ideas that you're talking about how
would it deal with the forces of
modernity
how would it deal with stem cell
research and we don't have to get into a
specific thing but all of the things
that science brings us and the good and
the bad that comes with the Internet
how would it actually negotiate that
modernity and secularism really that's a
great question
because our instruments are getting more
sophisticated as our capacity is getting
more multiplied but if our character
doesn't keep up with it we will just
have a more sophisticated way of
self-immolation and self-destruction you
know I had a guy at
in Canada stand up in the audience and
he said to me I can't buy into this kind
of worldview he said I think empirical
science all the time
that's my worldview the empirical
sciences so I said to him I agree with
you that empirical sciences of very
vital discipline in our times whether
it's full health was for understanding
the cosmos all of these I said let me
ask you this way the empirical scientist
in the lab is working away at research
why should he or she tell us the truth
when the research is done
what of the empirical sciences gives you
that imperative to be honest and tell
you the truth I said now you're into
metaphysics so it's not just physics so
I think the value structure and the
character has to start so did he ever
response that because I asked his
response would be something like well
his his code his internal code of ethics
would would force him to tell the truth
even if it was against his premise
essentially he just sat down he said I I
have to give that some thought because
you know in in in a cross-cultural
setting that doesn't necessarily follow
I work for example this great thing of
identifying a particular gene that they
were removing in China you know I think
you followed that yeah and all of a
sudden the Chinese government is
slapping this doctor with all kinds of
fines because he never got permission
for it and now they're finding out that
the implications of manufacturing that
kind of genetic code is fraught with all
kinds of dangers so the old adage holds
true now that knowledge is a deadly
friend when no one sets the rules the
fate of all mankind I see is in the
hands of fools or the rock musicians
told us that and musicians are often
more logical and those let us do
ordinary philosophy so I think what it
has to start with is this bottom line
question to me David what does it mean
to be human if we don't answer that
question everything else has footnotes
without a body of the substance so to me
I oftentimes speak on that subject what
does it really mean to be human why do I
have to respect your essential Worth
regardless of our disagreements why am I
sitting across you here actually thingy
I like this guy he's a good man he's a
he's a man who's thinking clearly and I
even if we have our fundamental
disagreements I have to respect your
right do your thinking and hopefully in
the end as we dialogue the truth will
have its way yeah you know it's funny
because I always say to Ben Shapiro who
you referenced before that whatever our
political disagreements are I suppose if
we can remain friends for another 50
years then maybe one of us will concede
a point here or there which I think
we've actually both done over just the
course of a couple of years but then at
the end it's like well then what's the
worst that happened you know we agreed
to disagree when I'm 94 and he's 87 yeah
and the truth of the matter is we can
disagree on the law of gravity but there
is the law we can disagree on the human
essence but there's only one explanation
of that human essence so you know
fascinatingly Jesus didn't persuade
everybody whom II spoke to there were
some that walked away and he looked at
some of them and said will you also
leave me at this point he looked at his
disciples the cost of truth is huge but
conviction with compassion is
indispensable
so you mentioned judeo-christian values
and since we've talked about Shapiro and
Dennis Prager who come at this obviously
from a Jewish perspective and you can
agree to disagree on whatever those
those outside issues are but when you
when you walk away from a conversation
with someone like the two of them or
someone from a different from not a
Protestant outlook on life etc do you
feel that they're missing something that
is a invaluable point to your worldview
well if truth by definition is exclusive
and if one disagrees with the other
there is still their necessity of the
truth you know Prager I thought had a
wonderful answer when we were talking
and he is very respectful to me as I am
of him and Prager looked at me and said
when Messiah comes
we'll have only one question for him
have you been here before and you know I
think that is that tells me how the man
is thinking but let me give you another
illustration there's a very great Hebrew
scholar in Jerusalem I was writing a
book on comparative worldviews and I
spent Samar's and and brilliant come I
say Sharon he is written more on the
inscriptions in the Middle East than
anybody else multiple volumes if I'm not
mistaken twenty or thirty volumes and he
looked at me on one point and he said
this he said mr. Zacharias you and I may
have our differences but we have learned
one very essential thing in common I
said what is that sir he said our goal
in life is to have communion with God I
said I agree with you and then he went
on to say something fascinating about
how he differed from other religious
world views on that matter but not with
the Christian worldview and that's why I
think the judeo-christian of you and man
Shapiro said to me you know what was
missing in the Ordos meant what was
wrong I said no it was not wrong it was
the gradual unfolding of that
relationship with God that we were
offered and that the grace that is given
to you and me right from the beginning
has hints of this and the mirror of the
law told me my face was dirty but the
mirror couldn't clean my face I had to
go to the faucet to find that cleansing
I said so it's a complimentary Ness and
a completion but to get to the heart of
your question yes I would go back and
say you know there's one link here that
is not as strong he may think the same
of me yeah so the way I come at it is
this there are tests for truth and there
are objects of those tests and I say
it's this there are really four
questions of life David origin meaning
morality and destiny that forms our
worldview where did I come from what his
life actually mean how do I
differentiate good and evil what happens
to human being when he or she dies and
therefore you put the two tests of truth
correspondence and coherence on my
answers corresponding to reality when my
answers are put together
is there a coherence to them and to me
in that judeo-christian worldview it
meets the duties of
coherence and correspondence with the
four questions of life so then from
there without getting too lost in the
politics of the day when I watch these
debates or just sort of anything that's
happening politically I always am
thinking well why would I want these
people to have any power over my life
they don't seem to be addressing
anything that that really matters right
they're not gonna really have an honest
you know they'll maybe ask them a quick
question on faith and they give you some
some glib answer or something like that
but I think part of the issue right now
is that they feel politicians feel they
can solve all of man's problems but you
would basically argue these are not even
for man to solve in the first place or
something like how I think politics is a
necessary evil in our time but a good
politician is the most difficult job in
our time and there are good people out
there I've met them I know them and they
are the ones who grieve most as to what
has happened somebody told me and from
the State Department I've been here
thirty years I've never seen the mood so
toxic as it is now we need it we need
these structures but I think we need
examples to model it not just to speak
it and most of the time as I said I'm
very troubled about what's happening
globally I see it I see two of the major
a theistic religions of the atheistic
countries of the world demagogues in
charge of the they're not giving their
people the freedom to believe or to
disbelieve while they are increasing
their footprint all over America what's
the thing you're talking about China
I don't Russia and Russia yeah and what
are we doing out here
we are fighting each other you know
there's an old adage how horses fight
and how donkey is fight when horses
fight they face each other form a circle
and the attacker comes and they kick
against the attacker but donkey is fight
they form a circle with their backs to
each other and face the attacker and
what do they do end up kicking each
other to death and so that's the way we
are doing politics not all by the way
there are good politicians there but
throwing the oil into the flame
one after another think of what the last
two years have been spent by politicians
doing peripheral stuff while we are
fiddling while Rome is burning here I am
talking to you in Los Angeles it grieved
me this morning to be sitting having my
breakfast in a restaurant of the bowl of
cereal and looking at the number of
homeless walking by it just crushed me
you know what has brought all this about
let's sit down and find a solution to
these think of the number of people
dying because of the opioid crisis think
of our young people who are battling the
destruction and the family and the home
and all of this we're not addressing any
of those things instead what were your
tax returns or it looks like we are only
only following the money trail we are
not following the trail of conscience
and cultural well-being well we seem to
be following the shiny object that's
ever moving and it provokes those who
are with you on your side you know I've
got to punch that guy in the face really
and then what my professor used to say
some people are better at smaller
smelling rotten eggs than laying good
ones and that's really what we're doing
to go back I think what we need is a
test of character not uniform in our
beliefs but a character that will hold
integrity as a primary method of
discourse if you lose that you lose the
discourse doesn't it seem though that
that would be almost impossible right
now to break through the ether which is
maybe why you said you think it's gonna
get worse before it's gonna get better
and I think some great tragedy will hit
us and then we will awaken is that it I
mean that I've said that once or twice
and I don't like thinking it you know I
mean you don't want to think that that
something horrific would have to happen
so that it would be the only way we
could reset which of course nobody wants
to happen and yet we find ourselves in
this weird thing it's like what else
what else would do it it's a good
question and
and a worthy question you know I don't
think there's a simplistic answer but I
just go with people whom I know in my
own heart
if everything is going well ok and then
you start worrying about your car you
know that you bought a lemon and it's
not running properly but all of a sudden
you find out one of your children or
grandchildren has just been hit in a car
wreck and their body is shattered it
changes everything of importance right
then and I know people to whom it's
happen they can be arguing and all of a
sudden they find out they've got cancer
of the pancreas or something and the
whole demeanor of life changes so that's
the way sometimes our attention is
brought to what really matters I'm
hoping what happens individually and
relationally with our friends it it
seems to be an intimation of how we
ultimately wake up to what's happening
think of the nuclear threat today who in
their right mind would want to see a
nuclear war you know we even just seen
pictures of Hiroshima and Nagasaki and
you say they were hell on earth but
we've got regimes with people who are
willing to do things like that so is it
going to take some awful cataclysmic
event for us to say stop everything has
to stop we have to sit down and talk I
don't know the only other possibility
David is this and that as a man who
loves Christ and loves the spiritual
world as reality some great revival
breaks out somewhere and hearts get
changed and we find a sympathy towards
things that really matter not towards
perfil issues that's always a
possibility it's happened in history a
dramatic change of heart of an
individual I see it happening in prisons
I see it happening in arenas and that
happens on a massive scale which is what
a Christian would call a revival and
that would be the only whole what do you
think the tough one what do you think
the sort of general state of happiness
is say across the world in that you know
we can look at or you we constantly
complain about everything and yes just
in the six years that I've lived in Los
Angeles now they're way more homeless we
layer absolutely and you know they can
talk about climate and all of these
things and yet there's so much counter
to that that infant mortalities the
louis has ever been that actually
there's more green on earth and we can
find all of these different studies
we've eradicated most diseases there's
less war right now than at almost any
time in human history all of these
things not to say there aren't bad
things but is there a way to sort of
measure happiness across time happiness
is treated as a thing to be pursued to
me it's a byproduct it is not you know
there's an old hebrew parable god is
like the light happiness and prosperity
is like the shadow you walk towards the
light the shadow will follow you you
turn your back upon the light and chase
the shadow you will never ever catch up
to it we have found means of
administering temporary happiness that
have actually cost us more in the long
run and therefore i think happiness
pursued is seldom attained the good
pursued produces the peaceful heart it
is really a question of are you at peace
you know Thomas Martin used to say man
is not being at peace with his fellow
man because not a piece of himself he's
not a piece of himself because not at
peace with God so let me take that
middle part if I am creating misery for
people around me and I'm roughing
people's lives up you know what that
tells people I am the one who's mister
inside it tells me more about myself
then about that person that's what I see
in our world today people are
distributing curses and displeasure
because they themselves have no peace
within their own heart if I'm at peace
in my heart David I'm not gonna be
coming and taking you out to spread some
kind of unhappiness or whatever you'll
see the overflow we've got to get to
what it really matters and that begins
with our children if we can impart to
our children a peaceful heart
a good and a decent heart think of what
is for example a few weeks ago I was
speaking at our own Institute in Atlanta
okay and those alive just had surgery
two days before that saw was very
uncomfortable and had come off an
intubation my voice was still raspy
but there was a lineup of people who
wanted to say hello and I knew I
couldn't stay any longer already on my
feet for so long so I looked down the
line and I saw a young boy and they
looked very disconsolate so I just waved
him over I said I'm leaving soon but you
look like a troubled man what's going on
can I help you
he said mrs. a cries I'm 13 years old in
11 days I'll be 14 and in lemon days I
have to go to court and choose between
our father and my mother
well yeah that's exactly what I felt
like a stab in my heart and no wonder
his face showed it now that's an issue
that's a problem but we don't address
how to build safe places for our
children to grow up and feel
unintimidated with their honest
questions and their struggles but if
you're falling apart in your own
relationships how do you impart it to
the children so I I just say if we have
nothing to give from within the peace in
our own heart
we are only distributing more
displeasure and unhappiness unhappiness
is also not gained it's a it's a symptom
of what is going on inside the person's
life I think that's the right way to end
a chat that felt right to me did that
feel right to you yes sir provided we
flip it and say you can find happiness
and peace by doing that which God has
called us to do so rather then on the
note of unhappiness on the note of
happiness that it can be gained because
the gift of God but thanks so much it
made me feel very comfortable here and I
hope we can do it again it was an
absolute pleasure I would love to do
again maybe we'll do it either with Ben
or with Dennis or we can get some of the
Atheist so we can maybe try Sam Harris
or Michael Shermer and and have that
conversation will
yeah and actually I'm going to be in in
Atlanta in October so I'd love to come
by and David yeah let us know the dates
if we're in town I'd be honored to host
you there and even maybe speak to our
staff and our people there yeah it would
be a pleasure well thank you so much for
coming anyway we see Internet we made it
happen there you go for more on Ravi you
can follow him on Twitter he's got good
branding it's at Ravi Zacharias if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlists there all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell